alger
aller vers lui dans ce question premier
manteau
voilà
oui oliver en paix les souvenirs bah je
fais souvent croisé l'aspect populaire
et
j'avais fait des chansons pour un big
mac de cette époque là c'était noël
descend nuit grandes idoles de bayon
ronnie bird deschamps
j'ai fait
non
atlantique ouais ouais ouais j'en ai
tellement six frappeurs nom sera pas
trouvée alors ces six frappeurs qui joue
qui joue à la guitare c'est pas ça me
pousse
j'ai pas joe torre non c'est presque
bah oui c'est vrai et ça c'est plus
ouais parce qu'il y avait en même temps
un bel outil l'orchestration se souvient
de cet album où il y avait d'un côté des
slows as coteaux iam formidable c'est ça
exactement l'europe le dit une seule
bien 2000 sonne et j'avais ça dans d'un
album à l'autre
il faisait les flots totalement
différent c'est farid des cordes
sauf que c'était un produit par john wes
et un pata lennon
il y avait toujours des grands musiciens
étaient de grands albums et singles
parce qu'il est pas et pas très connue
en france mais parfois inspirés de ses
passages coq à l'âne et il avait une
voix incroyable bien il va il a fait
tout un album aussi de chansons de randy
newman avec yellow man ce soir
bravo aux suivants ça c'est dur mais
c'est bien
pendant sa maîtresse a été chez lui tu
voyais les paralytiques était chez lui
dans sa cave en train de trafiquer les
sources dans son blizzard way superbe
je suis content que tu les trouves est
ce moi c'est à peine si tu trouves pas
bravo aux suivants
déjà plus facile
aux esprits comme ça tu vas connaître
tous les sons mardan
en attend ses sociétés soeurs jimmy
conway les jeunes et anne d'arrêter et
les abris car dans toulouse
j'aimais beaucoup un album acoustique de
new york selmi du loser c'est le fameux
newey a way est ce que tous les regards
doivent être des losers baccino ben
voilà on continue
je pense que je sois tu brûles qui brûle
quand tu lis tout juste eu brûle parce
que sur cet album il y avait beaucoup de
musique qu'elle était faite par
quelqu'un d'autre et ça c'est lui qui a
fait la musique
le lien qui unit pauvret s'exprime dans
quatre ans mais c'est pas facile mais tu
es un bon compte mais pas les plus
faciles c'est sixtine dans le sport live
et c'est pas beau week a fait la musique
et c'est bien que ces dix tout juste
parce que c'était son groupe avant au
suivant on peut fréquemment
l'ensemble semble zen 6 1 comment
c'était quand tu faisais les bases
américaines de des comme ça quand même
j'aurais bien voulu enregistrer cette
époque le red star de salon mais on
avait toujours le tracker rejouer
toujours très très vite le morceau je
crois qu'on a été pompé avons beaucoup
moins tu savais que ça se termine je
suis tombé sur un conte un jour qui m'a
dit il faut que ce soit fort et rapide
c'est dingue et c'est vrai et falloir
donc pas toujours le suivant question
ça c'est le must angeles
oui
mais pas le deuil de nom
ces gens ces genres de nos plus récents
puisque bonnel ouais bravo aux d'abord
celle des partis chez vous j'aime
beaucoup à briser bien pas très bien tu
veux tellement givré vrai mélange de pas
mal de musique entre du richard d rythm
and blues
c'est un des trucs qui va le plus éclaté
visuellement et musicalement on les a
eus dans un bain de minuit l'année
dernière pour les signaux après bravo
ces derniers boulevard lumumba qui loupa
1 puis devient ou s'il va très bien le
lien il tombé sur une espèce de yoko ono
du faux mais il va bien sergey enfin
faut faire gaffe
elle tient en un génie
l'histoire
robert hue